in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, from a first, on which we commemorate our venerable mother
Isadora the fool for Christ.
In the woman's monastery opposite the monastery of St. Pachomios of Tabanisi, on the other bank
of the Nile, there lived a nun who pretended to be mad and possessed of a demon in order
to bring the contempt of men on herself.
Dressed in rags, she did the meanest kitchen-jobs, and contented herself for food with the crumbs
she gathered from the tables.
One day St. Petitom, a famous ascetic, came to the monastery at the command of an angel and
asked to see all the nuns.
As they did not think it good to summon Isadora the fool, he had her brought, and when she
appeared prostrated at her feet, saying, bless me.
When they objected, saying that the nun was mad and to be despised, he replied that she deserved
to be the spiritual mother, Amma, of them all.
As although she had been subject to insult and scorn, her heart had never been estranged
from God.
After Petitom had left, the nuns incessantly made excuses and showed her marks of respect,
and this drove her to leave the monastery and end her days in a place unknown to anyone.
After the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.